in the late phases of donald trump's
second impeachment trial in which he was
acquitted over the weekend
details emerged about an absolutely
off-the-wall
phone call between donald trump and
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
which culminated with mccarthy screaming
at trump
who the f do you think you're talking to
which is not typically the way people
talk to presidents particularly when the
president is
of the same party both of the republican
party uh the call happened on january
6th
and the reason that mccarthy was on the
phone with donald trump in the first
place
was that he was begging trump to call
off the rioters explaining to trump
these are your supporters this is
terrible
call them off tell them to go home and
mccarthy
implored trump explaining the rioters
were breaking into his own office
through windows
and reportedly what set kevin mccarthy
off
was when donald trump continuing to
refuse to call them off
said well kevin i guess these people are
more upset about the election than you
are
that set mccarthy off into a tirade who
then said
who the f do you think you're talking to
now
layer one is that this is another
cartoonishly childish data point in the
trump presidency
trump unhinged ignorant absurd as a
participant in the
american political system but the bigger
takeaway is about the january 6th riot
because this call confirms that donald
trump obviously wasn't opposed to the
rioting we already knew that
but he also wasn't just an uninvolved
observer who may have liked it
he was being told as the president of
the united states
this is what these rioters are doing
these are your supporters
and he was pleased when he says to
mccarthy
call them off now these people they're
more upset about the election
results than you are that's a comment
that's supportive of the rioters trump
believes the writers are acting
correctly in relation to
uh what donald trump feels happened in
the election which is the big lie that
he repeated endlessly that it was stolen
and he really won
trump's mindset was call them off why
would i call them off they're angry for
the right reasons they're doing the
right things
and then of course hours later far too
late to have any impact
trump put out that pre-recorded uh video
half-heartedly saying it's time to go
home peacefully
but we love you and you're great people
and you're right to be upset but it's
time to go home now
this all took place in the midst of what
mike pence uh when mike pence was
in physical danger at the capitol on
january 6th and of course
trump knew about that and yet still went
on twitter and denounced mike pence
remember when trump tweeted we have to
now go into a deleted tweet archive to
get these because trump's twitter
account is banned
trump saying mike pence didn't have the
courage to do i'm sorry
yes trump said pence didn't have the
courage to do what should have been done
to protect our country
and our constitution giving states a
chance to certify a corrected set of
facts
not the fraudulent or inaccurate ones
which they were asked
to previously certify usa demands the
truth
when trump sent that at that point
trump knew pence was in danger and still
tweeted that
now once again kevin mccarthy is no
angel
in this kevin mccarthy is still merely
an amoral political opportunist how do
we know that
because just weeks after this call where
he said to trump
who the f do you think you're talking to
kevin mccarthy went down
and did his pilgrimage to florida at
trump's mar-a-lago
met with trump to recruit trump's help
in getting the house of representatives
back in 2022.
mccarthy learned nothing despite
everything that happened on january 6
flying down to beg trump for help
in the next election mccarthy still
standing by trump
and so these people deserve to be voted
out it's all just
at every point it's just how am i
affected by this
on january 6 protesters pro-trump
rioters were breaking into kevin
mccarthy's office so mccarthy said to
trump you got to stop this
and then trump didn't and so mccarthy
was furious it's just how does it affect
mccarthy
and then two weeks past that trump is
gone
democrats have the white house democrats
have the senate democrats have the house
and mccarthy wants to win it back well
if trump can help i'll fly down and
uh do my pilgrimage uh pray at the altar
of trump
down in muralago these people are
pathetic they deserve to keep losing but
it's up to us to make sure that they do
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat
this is not a random doctor on call each
doctor at steady md
has a limited number of patients so they
actually have time to listen to you
you get the personal attention that you
deserve they can do
almost everything an in-person doctor
can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you i took their quiz they matched me
with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video